[Music]
it's the oakster yeah so
how is the oafster doing well you're
we're lucky
you know why we're lucky
we get to live in the same time as a
radio legend
no i'm not kidding watch
uh do your kids know that you're a radio
legend i'm just their dad they don't
they don't give a crap they literally
notice notice something
notice something watch this
merch do me a favor ask me that same
question let's pretend i'm up he asked
me that same question hey uh royce do
your kids know that you're a radio
legend bro i wouldn't call myself a
radio legend don't call me that [ __ ]
that's ridiculous come on bro shut up
i mean i love doing radio but that's
pretty ridiculous did you see him
correct him
he didn't even correct him he just said
no he's like nah i know he didn't even
do the fake humble thing
uh do your kids know that you're a radio
legend i'm just their dad they don't
they don't give a crap they literally
don't know who anthony is they literally
don't know who jim norton is
well then why didn't they why did you
what no no no no no no no no
somebody just asked you a question yeah
about how your children perceive you
given your career over the years any
minute about anthony and you made it
about jimmy and anthony he made it about
jimmy and anthony immediately
immediately immediately
that's
[Music]
wow he's making his own stuff on his
ipad yeah he's making his own little
stingers you know he knows he's a pro
dude he knows you gotta have stingers
oh the microphone cause radio
yeah because he was i don't know if you
know this was he a rockabilly radio guy
was he mister
were you the big bopper yeah what
what
who are you mr anderson
i missed mr anderson
were you
were you a [ __ ] boxing announcer were
you about to say let's get ready to
rumble
what an [ __ ] uh do your kids know
that you're a radio legend um i i talk
about um
my past life let's call my past life i
kind of get what my dad
said um
at the end of his life that uh he he
lived a couple different lives because
my dad was married to his high school
sweetheart
she died at a very very young age of uh
i i believe a kidney disease which is
passively aggressively brought this up
to me on his death bed said he wished
she had never died
[ __ ] kids with a crazy woman after
that
which is something you can live with
more or less nowadays but it got her
back in the day and she and he also lost
two kids
then he turns around and he marries my
mom and has i don't know
seven eight nine kids well you should
know the number they're your siblings
seven eight or nine kids i kind of feel
like you should know the number right
officer
if they're your siblings
how do what kind of person doesn't know
how many siblings they have
and i asked my dad how he you know
dealt with the loss of his high school
sweetheart his first
wife and he uh he said that's fine but
why could why do we have to go to fh
riley's to have this conversation we
could have done it at home
and he and i said because we need the
business uh fair enough basically said
that uh he looks at it as kind of like
two different lives he lived
because he's like i can't imagine my
life without you kids
you know the ones he had with my mom
uh like [ __ ] the other kids that he did
without
like you know like [ __ ] them though like
right hope he's all over the place yeah
he's a [ __ ] mess
but uh
somebody brought up his kids and he went
right to anthony and jimmy dude he has a
problem i'm telling you
that's unhealthy
horrendous tragedy to get to that point
so that that's a little weird right
with that said um in my past life i was
a big radio star
relax
and now that my kids are a little older
i talk about my past life a little more
but in general i'm just their dad they
don't they don't give a crap
they don't give a crap they don't they
literally don't know who anthony is they
literally don't
to obsess about a show that hasn't even
been on the air eight years if my own
kids aren't talking about opium anthony
why are you
because some people like the show and
is he mad that people by by the way
opie's still posting clips from opie and
anthony on his page to get money right
but then at the same time
he's still monetizing his own a stuff
he's still posting clips from from that
era in his feed yeah of course he's
still he wants to squeeze money but he
wants to put it behind but at the same
time why are you why are you
why are you opie you pushed that
homeless mustard video so much you
basically killed him
figuratively allegedly jokingly
you try to get him to record the song
and the guy didn't want to remember that
yes he was like i'll play for the
recording studio but he me sirius would
pay for it but i'll pay for the
recording studio and he's like i don't
really want to do that he's like come on
he can force him into it
yes
i'll say this i'm not going to give the
guy like the
i've been of course not going to give
him any attention and three minutes
later and three minutes later i i've had
some level of fame since i was 18.
he said it he said the line come on man
he said the line he said the line he
said the line
he said the lying he's been doing this
since he was 18. by the way local radio
station at 18 is not really some level
of
fame with the opie anthony show my fame
was
it was through the roof
but say i wouldn't have i i've been i
i've had some sort of fame since i was
18 years old
he said it twice what a beef yes i i was
i i was before dorian he thinks he was
famous before anthony
but he wasn't he was a local radio guy
that nobody knew oh but he cared about
him he was a midday guy at wbab he's
pretending that he always was talented
you wouldn't be yes i i was
i i was before during and after after i
would definitely say no
after for sure i think we've established
he's right here i think we get
established definitely not not after uh
on the after part no
oh my god
if if my own kids aren't talking about
opium anthony why are you
your kids probably aren't even talking
about greg or daddy because you're at
the you're at the [ __ ] beach and all
you're doing is making these videos and
you're not what like this is the middle
of the day this isn't the time you
should be out on the beach with your
kids right like yeah that is the time
if you want to talk about some of the
fun stuff i get that i don't even have
kids and when i go on vacation i'm not
here doing this and when he goes on
vacation he's playing with kids so it's
super weird
yeah
but to obsess about a show that hasn't
even been on the air eight years my own
family doesn't talk about it everyone
because you're an embarrassment
once a while a very broad stroke
something comes up
that's it
oh my
god oh my god you're exhausting
but you're the one addressing it and
then clipping it
and then that's the only thing you're
addressing and clipping why are you
clipping it then opie it'll be fine if
it's exhausting fine
i get it it probably is
but but why are why are you keep
clipping it then i mean i mean i look
keep doing it
i i appreciate it it makes my life
easier because trust me when you clip
that kind of stuff i don't have to go
through an hour and 53 minute video of
you waiting to park your car across the
street
right
and again by the way more clips that he
had when he was on o and he's trying to
monetize he is such a piece of [ __ ] obi